[موسيقى]
هناك انظمه عربيه تطبع مع النظام السوري
باوامر من جهات خارجيه يعني باوامر مثلا
من ايران العراق ولبنان يطبعون مع النظام
السوري باوامر من ايران وربما هناك دول
تفعل ذلك بتاثير من روسيا ولكن غالبيه
الدول العربيه الانظمه العربيه وليست
الدول العربيه
تطبع مع النظام لانها تشعر بالتعاطف معه
لان الانظمه العربيه تخاف من اسقاط
الانظمه كلمه اسقاط نظام شعب اسقط نظاما
غالبيه الانظمه العربيه لا تحب ان تسمع
هذه الكلمه ولذلك غالبيه الحكام العرب
يتعاطفون مع بشار الاسد مع النظام السوري
لانهم في الهم واحد لانهم مثل بعض لانهم
يخافون من الشعوب ويكرهون ان الشعوب على
واحد منهم لانهم يعرفون بان العدوى سوف
تنتقل الى الجميع
او ربما ضد التطبيع مع النظام ربما لانها
لا تستطيع ان تبرر لشعوبها اقامه علاقات
مع نظام متوحش الى هذه الدرجه ونظام
انتقدته طوال عشر سنوات ولم يتغير لانه لم
يتغير لم يحصل اي تغيير في النظام لو
يتطور النظام السوري ولو خمسه بالمئه
تستطيع ان اوروبا ان تقيم علاقات معه
وتبرر اقامتها علاقات معهم ولكنه لم يتطور
اما امريكا فالموضوع مختلف امريكا موقفها
انها ضد التطبيع مع النظام لانها لا تريد
انتصار النظام الموقف الامريكي من اليوم
الاول هو ان لا ينتصر النظام ولا ينهزم
وان لا ينتصر الشعب السوري وان لا ينهزم
وان يستمر الحال كما هو عليه الان لا
هزيمه ولا انتصار
[موسيقى]
انطلقت الثوره السوريه لان العيش تحت ظل
هذا النظام شيء لا يتحمله البشر
هذا نظام ابادي يقتل الناس بمئات الالوف
ينهبهم بصوره مستمره منذ 53 عاما نهد
وتعذيب وقهر زائد اباده جريمه خاصه
بالاغلبيه السوريه اغلبيه العرب المسلمين
السنه هل نستمر في هذه الثوره ام لا سوف
نستمر لان الاسباب التي دفعتنا للثوره
كلها ما زالت موجوده وزادت